we really will pay it we're well paid
what's the problem why why do they need
to go groveling around the world trying
to get more money they didn't do
anything wrong they didn't do anything
wrong it's within the rules but it
shouldn't be within the rules the rules
should be that you have a job and you
should do that job and that should be
that's what the public expect it's a
hell of an honor to be an MP and it
ought to be it ought to take all your
time there are things that you can do I
think so I think you can do podcasts you
can appear on programs like this you
know you can write books and so on
particularly if you are continuing to
engage the public in in debate
um we have members of parliament who
work in the public sector who are also
nurses and care workers and doctors and
so on I think that that's probably quite
a good thing to do but going off and
having these of course you'd need to
declare it but the details of these
conversations the nature of these of
these relationships will largely be
secret and I don't think it's right and
care has made it perfectly clear that he
would not expect this and we would
expect we we want to set up an
alternative we want to have an
independent commission that will look at
standards make sure that we have clear
rules so that everybody knows when this
stuff happens it affects all of us all
MPS are tired with this and it's not
right it's not fair and you know some
parties you know it's not just the
tourists I mean someone your front bench
and take money for second jobs as well
don't they
David Lammy for example well I mean
David has a program on LBC and during
about the work that he does in the city
um offering lectures and the like how
does that benefit his uh constituents I
think that what we should be doing is we
should have clear rules about this and I
think that if you are engaging people in
in political debate that's fine you know
then I think that's part of your job as
a member of parliament is to do that but
I think going further than that is
something that we do need to change and
as I say you know this government has
been in power for 13 years and for the
government now to be saying oh we're
going to look at the rules now why
haven't they done it before is not to
say they haven't had scandal after
Scandal running up to now
what should we do about this immigration
bill that is coming before the house I
think again today
well Labor's going to vote against it
and we're going to vote against it
because it doesn't work you know we have
it is not going to stop any boats it's
not going to deal with people properly
when they arrive it's not going to send
anybody back it's not going to do any of
the things it's supposed to do all it
really is and I think that they've been
quite open about this is they're just
basically trying to start a fight
they're not expecting this legislation
to get anywhere but they want to kind of
make a big fuss about it and I genuinely
think that that's what Sue Ella Bradman
wants and she hasn't gone far enough
that people will be in Rwanda by the
summer yeah right as you're going to put
all of these people coming from all of
these boats over to Rwanda no it's not
even even if that works right even if it
was seen to be legal there still would
only be a tiny proportion of those who
are arriving on our Shores at the moment
will be sent to Rwanda where will the
rest of them go they're going to be put
into indefinite detention we don't know
where it will include women who have
been trafficked it will include genuine
Asylum Seekers it will include children
and we're going to just lock them up in
Camp somewhere forever you know we need
to have a proper agreement with other
countries in order to return people we
need to have properly we need to we need
to look at we need to go for the gangs I
mean most of the people two-thirds of
the people in The Gangs we're told
actually live in the UK does this
legislation
but what are they doing about that um
you say labor is backing an amendment
calling for fast tracks for Asylum uh
Seekers from safe countries what
constitutes a safe country
well it would be if someone is coming
from one of the European countries but
they want to be able to so they've
arrived in Europe but they want to be
able to to reunite with the rest of
their family so perhaps one of the
members of the family has come through
as a refugee and they want to reunite
with their with their children or their
husband or whatever then we should have
an easier way of being able to
fast-track people into the country that
way rather than them kind of getting
desperate and ending up taking Reckless
measures like getting onto a small boat
and coming across the channel what about
and safe countries sending people back
to places like Albania yeah so what we
need to do is we need to be focusing our
our efforts on making sure that we have
proper relationships with these
countries and working with them you know
going outside the international law for
example if this legislation does which
challenged and we'll see but you know
there's constant kind of trying to goad
um the rest of the World by saying that
they are prepared to break international
law does not help when you're also
trying to come to agreements with these
countries to for them to accept people
to come back
um let's move on to um the children's
Minister who says that black kids are
six times more likely to be stopped and
searched than others and we're also
hearing about child Q who was strip
searched naked while she was having her
period what what's Labor's stance on
this well it's absolutely disgusting I
mean I didn't actually think that
there's disagreement between the
political parties on this I think that
we all think that it's appalling and we
all wonder how on Earth we got to this
situation where this is in some way
acceptable for children to be strip
searched at the age of eight it really
isn't acceptable and I think that we do
need to do some serious work on this and
look again at the culture and the police
where they think that this is right I
think that a lot of what Louise Casey
said is a relevance to this but yes
there needs to be work on this we cannot
yeah we cannot continue like just let me
ask you a thought with your previous
hash on when you were Shadow foreign
secretary president
um or Netanyahu
um he visited London last week met by
protests here lots of protests at home
as well he wants to change the law
doesn't it basically what he wants to
happen is make it more difficult for
people who are not necessarily the right
person for the job to be removed from
that job what would you say to that I
think it's also that he also wants to
have political appointments of judges
and I when I've been in Israel and I've
visited many times I've spoken to people
throughout Society including some very
senior judges who are proud of the fact
that they have an independent legal
system independent of politics yeah
that's what the rule of law is about and
it needs to be applied equally to
everybody and any attempt to undermine
that has caused huge concern
internationally but also within Israel
which is why I wish to him I think they
should they should pull it I mean I just
think that they should think again I
mean the trouble is it's a very
authoritarian regime and it relies on
some very hard right people in order to
be able to remain in power and so their
worry is if they do anything about it
then they then the government May
collapse I'm afraid for the sake of the
future of of the democratic future of
Israel they need to pull this
legislation Emily Thornbury always a
pleasure thank you very much India for
joining us thank you